äh wir machen das Fragen Lotto ähm das
sind gute und böse Fragen harmlose und
gemeine die roten sind die gemeinen die
Grünen die harmlosen ihr könnt selber
ziehen und entscheiden die roten sind
die gemeinen ja okay ne wir die gemein
gut
ähm die Frage stelle ich an ludriich
dadurch dass ich sie auspacke findet ihr
nicht auch dass Raumanzüge nur den
Background Tänzern von Lady Gaga
stehen also denen stehen die natürlich
ganz hervorragend das war elich auch so
eine der Hauptinspiration warum wir uns
dann auch welche besorgt haben aber wir
finden elich mittlerweile uns stehen die
auch ganz gut und bei uns ist halt die
Idee einfach nur dass wir als
Privatperson so ein bisschen hinter
unserer Musik zurücktreten wollen
deswegen uns die Idee uns ein dress
zuzulegen
okay sehr gut sehr gut nehmen wir noch
mal eine gemeine oder
a so diesmal ich
stell
so seid ihr privat zur abgekühlt wie
euer Name
ähm ich glaube wir sind eigentlich
prinzipiell
sehr normale Menschen bedeutet dass wir
eigentlich jede gefühlsschwankung in uns
haben die jeder andere auch in sich hat
und abgekühlt sind wir glaube ich nicht
ich glaube wir haben auch viel Spaß gut
next f die roten die
roten oder sind die Grünen
besser sind alle gleich schlecht Nein
sie haben halt ihre
Nachteile Geigenmusik und köre ist das
nicht ziemlich
kitschig also wenn man die kianischen
chorelle kitschig fand und
ähm vielleicht auch Bach dann würde ich
sagen findet man wahrscheinlich gesamte
Musikgeschichte kitschig und deshalb ähm
ist die Frage ganz klar mit Nein zu
beantworten denn diese Sounds haben
eigentlich ein Großteil unserer
westliche Musikgeschichte mit
begründet das stimmt wohl wenn ihr Bach
sagt habt ihr da auch eine gemeinsame
Vergangenheit mit dem Herrn in in einem
Bekannten Chor oder
ähnlichen lu ich also l Vater ist ja mit
Johann Sebastian Bach verwandt nein ja
ja okay wusste ich nicht aber Felix ich
glau auch hat als großes Hobby die
Ahnenforschung für sich entdeckt gerade
eben wie schafft ihr das so viel
musikalische Vielfalt in ein Stück zu
bekommen okay also die Frage haben wir
von im Prinzip schon so ein bisschen
beantwortet bzw Felix dadurch dass wir
eben diese sechs Leute in der Band sind
die ja einfach alle musikalisch sehr
interess und wirklich in alle Richtungen
irgendwie ihre Fühler so ausstrecken und
dass im eben Einflüsse
von Bach bis
bethofen und
brahs
und b b
genau so eben genau das ja einf einfach
wirklich ganz weit gestreut sind d das
soür und dass wir
eben das zulassen dass jeder so ein
bisschen seine Persönlichkeit mit
einfließen lassen kann deswegen kommt
diese Vielschichtigkeit
Zustande gut sehr schön vielen
Dank